by now I'm sure most of you have heard
about Teemu they're the sketchy online
retailer that sells counterfeits and
unbelievably cheap items if you're not
familiar with teu just take a look at
what happens if you look up Apple watch
on teu you get all these results that
only cost $10 to $25 and that's not just
for the band it's for the entire watch
itself it's the same thing if you look
up Apple airpods you get a bunch of
knockoffs that are as cheap as $4
obviously these counterfeits don't quite
stack up to the real deal but for the
price they're actually insane often
times you can't even tell which one is
fake and which one is real even when
they're side by side it's not just
electronics that are cheap on Teemo
either everything from shoes and
sweatshirts to power tools and pet
supplies can be found for ridiculously
cheap prices on Teemu and if you think
that all of this seems too good to be
true well then it's because it is the
only reason te was able to sell all of
these items for so cheap is because they
take a massive loss on each and every
item sold in fact according to wired
team was losing an average of $30 on
every single order which added up to
over $3 billion in losses last year and
I think now would be a good time to
mention that teu wasn't even launched
till September of 2022 so they haven't
even been in business for 18 months at
this point and their burn rate is
already over $3 billion per year but
they there is Method behind all the
madness thanks to team's promotional
prices they've exploded in popularity
within a matter of 18 months they've
been able to take on Amazon and all of
the other physical retailers they've
also been able to go from 0 to 89th most
visited website within the US and 148th
most visited website in the world
pulling in over 400 million visits every
single month for perspective they pull
in more traffic than established media
Outlets like Fox Business and BC new
news CNBC and AP news and that's just
their website Teemo is often the most
downloaded app within the US on both the
IOS app store and the Google Play Store
in any given month so who exactly are
the people behind teu and will they
actually make it to the other side or
are these losses going to end up killing
them from the inside
out taking a look back the story of M
takes us back to a middle class Chinese
man named Colin hang or hang Jen Colin
was born in Jing China on January first
1980 to two Factory workers as you could
guess Colin really didn't start off with
much and he would follow the path of any
hardworking Asian immigrant he would
study his butt off and get into one of
the most prestigious universities in
China jaying university where he majored
in computer science from there he would
turn around and attend the University of
Wisconsin where he would obtain a MERS
in computer science
this background allowed him to score
internships at Microsoft and Google and
received job offers from several top
tier tech companies including Microsoft
Oracle IBM and Google who at the time
was just a small startup but on the
recommendation of one of his friend/
mentors William ding who is a multi-a
billionaire today himself Colin would
end up joining Google as a full-time
software engineer in 2004 this would
turn out to be a brilliant move as
Google would go public that same year
and they would reach a $100 billion
market cap just one year later this
meant that Colin's stock compensation
went to the moon and he would become a
multi-millionaire by his mid-20s for
most Asian immigrants this is where the
arc would naturally come to a conclusion
from here they would just work up the
corporate ladder into the upper echelons
of management and executive leadership
and that would pretty much be it but
Colin would become part of a growing
group of Asian immigrants who were
interested in bringing American Tech
back home to China technically
techically this was actually also his
official job at Google itself he was
supposed to help Google with their
expansion in China but this didn't work
out all that well as Google wasn't
really able to compete against Chinese
giants like B Colin saw the riding on
the wall by 2007 and he would leave
Google to create his own e-commerce
startup called oku in China oku was just
your run-of-the-mill e-commerce
electronic shop thanks to how big the
internet is oku was able to achieve
moderate success in the millions of
dollars but it didn't even hold a candle
against real giants like Alibaba jd.com
and tensent as such Colin would end up
flipping oku for $2.2 million in 2010
and start looking for a new angle within
the e-commerce Market this sort of
spiritual journey ended up taking
multiple years and at one point he even
consider moving back to the United
States and just opening up a tech hedge
fund but eventually he would find his
unique angle in 2015 thanks to the rise
of mobile social media col and noticed
that there were massive online retailers
like Amazon and Alibaba and massive
social media giants like Facebook and
tension but there was no one who was
trying to do both at the same time and
this would end up being the unique spin
that he would integrate into his new
e-commerce business in
2015 the goal of this business was to
gamify shopping like never before by
combining the most addictive parts of
shopping and the most addictive parts of
social media and you would call it Pino
Duo
pindu Duo was exactly the e-commerce
breakthrough that Colin was looking for
that could take on the Chinese Giants
what did pindu Duo do that was so unique
you ask well like teu it offered rock
bottom prices but instead of the price
being subsidized by pindu Duo it was
subsidized by scale for example users
might see an ad about how they could get
groceries like fruits and vegetables for
half the price but there was just one
catch to get the groceries for half the
Sur price you needed to recruit 5050 or
100 people to buy it with you the more
people you recruited the lower the price
and given that pin duo duo wasn't
selling smartphones and computers or
something and instead selling simple
cheap everyday Goods that everybody
needed it was quite easy to recruit
people because the ask was so small and
straightforward you could share it with
your friends and family or the people in
your apartment or your classmates and
colleagues together you could all save
25 or 50% on everyday goods and on the
flip side pinu Duo just got 50 or 100
repeating customers by advertising to
just one person and that's just a first
cycle imagine what happens when each of
those 50 people tell 50 more people the
network effect simply becomes ridiculous
and that's exactly what happened before
you knew it pindu Duo would become a
sizable player within the Chinese
e-commerce Market as of 20123 they stood
at 17.4% market share across the country
and Colin would simply fuel this fire
with prac practices that he learned from
Google for example instead of trying to
pay Engineers as little as possible he
would pay them 30% more than they would
earn at Alibaba and 60% more than they
would earn at jd.com also instead of
hiring candidates with Decades of
experience Colin would hire fresh
college graduates who are hungry for
success and I think this chart tells you
everything you need to know regarding
what happened next Pino Duo would
essentially grow from 0 to $18 billion
worth of annual revenue within a matter
of 6 years and it was from this
Mountaintop that Colin would launch
Teemu the concept behind teu is also
extremely simple it's no secret that
basically all of the listings on Amazon
and Shopify are just highly marked up
lowquality goods from China and people
are not only starting to notice but
they're getting frustrated why pay $20
for something that you can get from
Alibaba for $5 at least then the quality
will match the price there's just one
problem with this logic though the
average Western isn't familiar with
Alibaba or
AliExpress all they know is that their
Amazon purchases are and that's
where timu comes in timo's main goal has
been to bridge this knowledge Gap and
show people that they can buy the same
stuff they get on Amazon for way cheaper
now I should mention that Alibaba has
been trying to do this with AliExpress
since
2010 but let's just say that Alibaba
never understood social media the same
way that timu does which brings us into
teemu's brilliant launch
strategy timu strategy was actually
extraordinarily simple instead of
spending Millions on Google ads or
influencer sponsorships Teemo decided to
spend Millions on brilliantly positioned
giveaways teimo basically went out and
purchased thousands if not tens of
thousands of legitimate products that
westerners wanted like Nintendo switches
they didn't just straight up give these
away though if they had had just won a
giveaway no one would have batted an eye
it would have just been seen as an
obvious promotional event instead what
teu did was price these products at
ridiculously low prices for example they
offered the switch for just $7 all of a
sudden Teo was able to create an insane
amount of mystery and Intrigue as to
what exactly was going on here is it a
scam is it a counterfeit were these
units stolen you know all those normal
natural questions as such 9 99.99% of
the people who saw this probably
chuckled and moved on but
0.01% thought hey this is probably a
scam but it's only $7 I'll just use my
burner PayPal account to pay for it if I
get it I get it if I don't I don't and
to their surprise they actually ended up
receiving the switch and it's not a
counterfeit or stolen unit either it's
straight up legit this only has to
happen to a few hundred people before it
becomes International headline and
millions of people are talking about it
on social media and that's exactly what
happened honestly credit to Teemu for
running such a genius marketing campaign
in terms of ratio between exposure and
dollar spend this was probably one of
the best campaigns in history basically
overnight hundreds of millions of people
discovered Teemu and when they check out
the website or app they'll see that they
can't quite get a switch for $7 every
single day of the week but they can get
products that are way cheaper than on
Amazon or American retailers and
naturally a lot of people became quite
interested and honestly I think that's
great because it's about time that we
stop overpaying for junk on Amazon and
drop shipping stores in terms of the
viability of timu normally burning $3
billion per year would be an extremely
dangerous game to play even with a bunch
of EC Capital but luckily for timu
they're backed by the giant that is
pindu Duo who is currently worth $128
billion
so it's highly likely that teu is here
to stay and they're only going to grow
in popularity with that being said
though if you're going to buy on teu you
should be wary of two things number one
teu is not a scam but they do have a
terrible customer support because the
entire platform is essentially just a
bunch of Chinese factories and
warehouses that don't really care about
the customer experience so it's quite
possible that your order gets lost and
that you have no recourse so definitely
be careful about how much you spend on
timu and what exactly you buy and as for
number two well I'm not trying to steer
type here but timu is almost certainly
installing spyware malware tracking a
bunch of your data and who knows what
else in fact Pino Duo was removed from
the Google Play Store for exactly those
reasons with that being said though if
it's not Teemu that's tracking you it's
going to be Google Facebook and all of
the other American Tech Giants so it's
really up to you as to whether you're
okay with a Chinese company doing the
same thing but either way this is only
the beginning of teu and Chinese Tech in
general and it's going to get a lot
crazier from here Tik Tok has already
started implementing some brilliant
strategies to ensure that they never get
banned in the US check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next
one